No matter how much time is spent writing the
perfect script, or assembling the perfect
cast, a single celebrity appearance can wind
up being the only thing audiences talk about.
Whether it's adding to the story, delivering
an unexpected gag, or just an incredible moment
that fans might not even catch, the right
cameo can take a movie from good to great.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Movie Cameos
You've Never Seen.
Jurassic World (Universal)
Corporate branding was a major plot point
in the Jurassic Park reboot, which meant the
bigger, better dinosaur park featured an IMAX
theatre, and even Jimmy Buffet's Margaritaville,
the chain of restaurants founded by the famous
singer. When the customers are sent scrambling
by attacking pteradons, it's hard to miss
one man who doesn't want to lose his margaritas
in the chaos. The best part: that's Jimmy
Buffett himself, apparently more worried about
keeping his costs down than a pack of killer
dinosaurs.
Star Trek Nemesis (Paramount)
Some directors like to keep their favorite
TV shows and movie franchises to themselves,
but director Bryan Singer was an obvious Star
Trek fan long before he helmed the big screen
reboot. He even included a nod to the original
series in his X-Men universe, but it was Next
Generation star Patrick Stewart who scored
him a cameo in Star Trek: Nemesis officially
making him an in-universe crew member of the
USS Enterprise.
Guardians of the Galaxy (Marvel/Disney)
From the moment James Gunn got the job of
writing and directing Marvel's space adventure,
fans knew that actor Nathan Fillion would
have to make an appearance, having starred
in Gunn's previous movies Slither and Super.
Rumors spun out of control claiming the Firefly
star would play one of a dozen cosmic heroes,
but in the end, most casual fans probably
missed his cameo altogether. The actor's sense
of humor wasn't used to play an outlaw, Ravager,
or goon - just a prison inmate promising to
put Star-Lord through a night he'd never forget.
It's a
smaller role than fans hoped for, but you
can't say it's not a memorable one.
Indiana Jones and The Temple of Doom (Paramount)
Raiders of the Lost Ark was a universal hit,
but fans are a bit more divided on its prequel,
Temple of Doom. So some Indiana Jones fans
may not have realized that Ghostbusters star
Dan Akroyd makes a blink-and-you-miss-it appearance
sending Indy onto an airplane out of Shanghai.
The actor made the cameo since he was a close
friend to director Steven Spielberg - who
can also be spotted, along with producers
George Lucas, Frank Marshall and Kathleen
Kennedy dressed as missionaries in the same
scene!
Ghostbusters (Columbia Pictures)
Ron Jeremy may be better known for his career
inadultfilms, but he's made at least one
Hollywood appearance worth watching. When
the containment unit at Ghostbusters headquarters
is turned off in the first movie, it releases
every ghost, spectre or spirit the team has
caught. It sends the movie to its climax,
and Ron Jeremy is there to see it firsthand,
in an uncredited cameo among the New Yorkers
gathering to see the explosion.
Hot Fuzz (Universal/Rogue)
Seeing a famous actor or director in the background
of a movie is a fun thing to watch out for,
but what about celebrities put right in the
spotlight without fans ever noticing? Director
Edgar Wright packed too many cameo to count
into his buddy-cop action comedy, but two
stand out for theireyesalone. The man
dressed as Santa Clause putting a knife through
the hero's hand in flashback is Lord of the
Rings mastermind Peter Jackson, and his masked
girlfriend--make that ex-girlfriend--is played
by none other than Oscar-winning actress Cate
Blanchett.
Spaceballs (MGM)
The Star Wars parody from Mel Brooks is filled
with inside jokes and slapstick humor, but
it wasn't just George Lucas's trilogy that
got sent up in the movie. When the hero Lone
Starr and his partner Barf stop in at a space
truckstop, they get a front row seat for a
horror show. Reenacting the chestburster scene
from Alien would have been a good enough joke,
but actually having Oscar nominated actor
John Hurt reprise his role as the alien's
victim is too good a cameo to believe.
Dumb & Dumber To (Universal)
The original Farrelly Brothers movie starring
Jim Carrey and Jeff Daniels was a hit from
the start, but the sequel released twenty
years later... wasn't. Oscar winner Jennifer
Lawrence may have had her brief scene cut
from the movie completely, but one incredible
cameo made it through. Most viewers will recognize
that Harry's new roommate, Icepick, is a crystal
meth cooker torn right out of AMC's Breaking
Bad - what they won't recognize is that it's
one of the directors' friends under the mask:
Bill Murray.
Mallrats (Gramercy Pictures)
Today, every fan of X-Men, Spider-Man, or
Marvel's Avengers universe knows Stan Lee,
the creator of some of the most famous superheroes
in comic book history. That's thanks to his
almost mandatory cameos that fans know to
watch out for. But long before his characters
were dominating the box office, it was director
Kevin Smith who knew a brief appearance from
the Marvel icon in his second movie would
send comic book nerds into a frenzy. Lee's
scene is probably the funniest, and most dramatic
one he's ever turned in, playing along with
the movie's crude humor, and even delivering
a heart-to-heart for the ages - even more
impressive since he made it all up.
Hook (TriStar Pictures)
This re-imagining of Peter Pan was meant to
be a children's movie, but there were plenty
of kid who couldn't handle the infamous "Boo
Box" - Captain Hook's punishment for men in
his crew who doubted his plan. But the pirate
who wound up locked in the box with some scorpion
friends wasn't a man at all, but actress Glenn
Close in disguise. Apparently it pays to have
Steven Spielberg as a director, since he also
roped in George Lucas and Carrie fisher to
play the kissing couple accidentally sprinkled
with fairy dust.
Those are the best celebrity cameos we noticed
in our favorite films, but which ones do you
think we missed? Be sure to name them in the
comments, and remember to subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this one.